ça a été la première en fait à apporter
un peu le musical pour les enfants aussi
avec tes mises en scène le château hanté
la forêt magique tout ça
que elle vient d'inventer musical pour
enfants alors moi j'étais venu juste
pour chanter pour rire avec tout le
monde et je sais que Jean-Jacques
m'avait engueulé pardon m'avait attrapé
il m'avait dit mais tu vas aller à
l'Olympia mais tu te rends compte c'est
là où il y a chaque Brel Edith Piaf et
tout et tous ceux que j'aime et
s'entraîner j'ai même pas j'irai sur le
côté et puis je les laisse au milieu
c'est pas grave et voilà puis ça a
commencé là alors Chantal Goya né de
guerre tu es né à Saigon tu as lorsque
tu avais trois ans ta famille a fui le
pays évidemment car c'était le c'était
l'Indochine française et puis là c'était
l'indépendance c'était les débuts des
conflits de l'indépendance etc et après
tu es parti vers directe derrière tu as
évité une mort certaine parce que
c'était très violent oui mais ma mère
m'a toujours habitué à nous battre même
petit elle nous est la vérité disait
aujourd'hui ça va être très compliqué
mon papa va arriver il sera peut-être
plus là et moi j'étais tellement une
révolté en moi mais je disais jamais tu
rends pas c'est pas possible j'étais
haute comme ça c'est fou j'ai sauvé ma
famille et puis on est rentrés en France
c'est le lieu de mon enfance et de mon
adolescence et après tu as fait tes
études à Paris avant de partir pour
l'Angleterre ou tu as passé ton bac au
lycée français de Londres
parce qu'il fallait bosser à la maison
on était obligé c'était le terme de
maman on est obligé ok on est obligé
mais je me suis pas réveillé pour l'oral
alors pas vraiment il m'a dit bon arrête
maintenant ça suffit les conneries je
t'envoie l'Angleterre dans une famille
et tu vas aller là-bas et tu seras très
heureuse et là j'ai jamais été aussi
heureuse parce que j'ai rencontré les
gens merveilleux qui s'appelaient le duc
la duchesse de Bedford rien que ça ah
oui il y avait un dîner Michael Caine et
les Beatles
mais il y avait pas de portable on peut
pas faire de photos
tu fais la rencontre de ta vie une photo
avec les Beatles j'aurais touché
j'ai rencontré Jean-Jacques à cette
époque voilà regarde tu avais 17 ans et
puis là je me suis dit je vais être
journaliste il m'a présenté à Daniel
Philippe Paqui et moi je me suis dit on
a le plus grand journaliste devant nous
je vais demander d'être correspondante
d'un journal français qu'un journal
anglais parce que je savais ce que je
voulais mais fallait que je les
connexions mais à l'époque c'est pas
compliqué on devrait la porte on
discutait puis ça y est seulement quand
Daniel m'a vu il a dit oh là là elle est
tellement photogénique je voudrais
qu'elle chante ah non c'est pas possible
très fort on va pas m'emmener avec Tommy
et tout ça moi j'ai posé
et puis du coup Daniel il m'a dit non je
voudrais qu'elle chante c'est pas
possible et dans la rue il y avait un
gamin qui s'appelait Bernard et
Jean-Jacques le dit tu t'appelles
comment Bernard il a fait c'est bien
Bernard le plus veinard de la banque
c'est le premier titre ça oui mais moi
je vivais à Londres j'étais avec les
Beatles j'étais pas avec Bernard et puis
du coup mais c'est qui c'est
toi là
on était toujours ensemble
et Jean-Jacques est là évidemment très
malin très malin j'adore Chantal depuis
on leur envoie depuis quelques années
j'adore Chantal de toute façon alors
effectivement alors tu as aussi démarrer
au cinéma aussi une époque parce que tu
étais la petite mignonne que tout le
monde voulait et il faut quand même le
dire et puis la Nouvelle Vague Jean-Luc
Godard tombe sur toi masculin il te
voyais un peu la télé dans les
figurations des choses comme ça parce
que là féminin oui mais j'avais dit je
vous préviens Jean-Luc moi je viens
tourner mais j'embras personne je vais
pas dans le lit les garçons j'ai déjà
tout à la maison ça me suffit mais tu as
une éducation très stricte non ben je
comprenais pas qu'on pouvait coucher
avec un mec pendant au cinéma je
comprenais rien de tout ça
surtout toi Jean-Michel ah Jean-Michel
effectivement
il m'avait fait tourner une scène à poil
j'avais déjà négocié avec Marlène Jobert
qui ferait le rôle à ma place ça tout
était déjà négocié et puis là-dessus
quand il a ouvert la porte mais
qu'est-ce que tu fous sous le sous
lavabo ce que je fais c'est que je peux
pas je veux pas tourner à poil c'est
tout je voulais dire il m'a dit vous
serez jamais une vedette et je m'en fous
jamais à la maison c'est ma machine à
laver et voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime beaucoup d'aventures avec les
metteur en scène parce que je voyais
vite que leur fantôme c'est leur
fantasme caché c'était de me mettre à
poil et comme je vois à travers les gens
je sais ah celui-là il va pas y arriver
pourquoi tu voulais absolument pas être
une scène dans une scène nue
Chantal jamais jamais à poil mais c'est
même pas possible dans ma tête je suis
très pudique moi que déjà au Palais des
Congrès il me faut trois paravent trois
culottes et là je suis bien
trois culottes
je crois mais bon
avec votre vrai nom de ces deux guerres
non magnifique moi je l'aurais gardé si
ça m'était le mien parce que mon père
m'a dit ma petite Chantale si tu veux
être une artiste tu changes de nom parce
que ça marche pas de quoi on aura l'air
je dis pas il y a pas le même je vais à
Biarritz chez un grand ami qui s'appelle
Guy d'arkand
mais j'ai vu son fils dernièrement et il
m'a dit il y a un Goya dans le salon
j'étais émerveillé et là il m'a dit
regardez
il vous ressemble
goyache la bon ben on va le faire
elle a joué quand même à la tournée avec
les plus grands hein Gainsbourg
Depardieu
dans le taxi tu enlèves ta main tout de
suite
je voulais voir un extrait peut-être de
masculin féminin quand même parce que
c'était tellement beau ce film de Godard
il est toujours
[Musique]
trop menti tu connais c'est mon adresse
tu ne m'as pas écrit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'attends des que reviennent les codes
la plus beau jour
Chantal Goya et notre amitié qu'est-ce
que ça te fait Chantal de revoir ces
images tu sais moi je suis quand même
quelqu'un de spécial parce que j'ai
emmené ma petite fille il y a 2 ans du
cinéma à Paris voir le film que j'ai
tourné puis elle m'a dit mais dis donc
tu te rends compte que tu as fait JB
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait j'ai tous les
Marlène Jobert et Jean-Pierre Léo il m'a
dit mais tu étais un couple à trois j'ai
à trois mais je savais même pas moi-même
elle était tellement gentille qu'elle me
faisait des caresses et tout ça c'est
une vraie copine
et j'ai découvert ça après j'ai dit bon
bah voilà c'est marrant n'arrive pas à y
croire
parce que par contre mais tu as toujours
un sentiment de montrer que tu es naïve
non mais c'est pas de la naïveté c'est
qu'elle est très déterminée
je sais ce que c'est attends on va pas
me voilà
moi je vais tourner en Allemagne et puis
tout d'un coup ils m'ont dit il y a
votre fiancé qui arrive je relax ce qui
va arriver derrière les bois un bonhomme
épouvantable la mèche d'Hitler et la
moustache il y a plus de 6 mois je
tourne pas vous tourner en haut moi je
m'en vais à terminer
2 jours ah oui mais moi j'adore mais non
mais c'est pas ça c'est que j'ai pas une
cariériste je suis quelqu'un qui aime
les gens avec mon naturel et ma façon de
spontanée tu es spontanée
Philippe
spontanéité vraiment Chantal tu parles
tu y vas j'adore ça moi j'aime bien
parler parce que la maison je parle pas
et c'est Jean-Jacques qui parle
alors tu as raison avec nous parle alors
justement on va clore le chapitre cinéma
parce que tu as fait beaucoup de cinéma
avec les plus grands oui par Dieu qui
était le facteur qui avait jamais tourné
absolument
toute la journée il est comment le génie
j'ai bah attends on va le faire venir un
jour non mais j'ai eu des relations
merveilleuses avec beaucoup Bernadette
Lafont et
et Jean-Pierre Marielle devait faire le
rôle d'une avec un sac j'ai vu
comment on fait ça il me dit bah tu fais
comme ça
mais dis-moi tu devais faire les taux
d'Alfred Hitchcock mais tu étais
enceinte de ton de ton gosse de Massy
Clarisse je peux pas je peux pas être
maman et c'était tourné c'est pas
possible c'est pas grave il a fait les
oiseaux puis il a pas fait Goya c'est
pas grave
quand par contre je lui ai dit j'ai une
bonne copine qui s'appelle Claude Jade
vous devriez la prendre parce qu'elle
est c'est toi qui l'a recommandée
ah bon mais c'est pas possible alors
s'engueuler encore une fois et puis du
coup elle l'a fait quand même et alors
oui c'est un très beau film avec picoli
aussi d'ailleurs il y a noir et aussi
dedans alors c'est à la carrière la
chanson qui démarre c'était en 75 c'est
là que vraiment ça prend son envol hein
je crois parce que tu es appelé par nos
amis maritis Gibert Carpentier
évidemment pour leur top à Sylvie je
crois d'abord
tous les personnages et maritime
m'appelle mais ma petite Chantal
Brigitte Bardot est malade est-ce que de
la remplacer j'ai en remplace pas
brigitte c'est quand tu as chanté à Dieu
les foulards
la bonne copine qu'on plaçait au dernier
moment et ça m'amusait comme j'étais à
Paris je tournais à rond dans les cafés
en attendant l'émission soit terminé
alors hop je partais au but de Chaumont
et là je fais des petites filles modèles
avec Sylvie mais en fait
avec billon on était par terre et
pendant Jean-Jacques chanter on buvait
des cours de la grenadine et du bon vin
alors c'est drôle parce qu'en fait
c'était Brigitte Bardot qui était
pressenti pour cette chanson elle était
malade pour une autre chanson et
maritime m'appelle elle dit demande à
Jean-Jacques de t'écrire vite une
chanson parce que comme ça tu peux la
remplacer j'ai Brigitte l'oiseau je
remplace pas Brigitte Bardot c'est pas
possible j'aime tellement et elle était
là avec nous on se voyait tout le temps
à l'époque
qui a fait cette photo et là Madrague
évidemment et vous savez on va se faire
un petit plaisir on va écouter un peu là
j'adore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
3 minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
je me souviens c'est en l'honneur de ma
grand-mère et de maman qui sont nés en
Martinique une cousine de Philippe Lavil
et on voulait rendre hommage à ma
famille et cette chanson est devenue une
comment dire plus de 500000 lettres sont
arrivés chez les carpentiers
qui est adorable c'est ça qui t'as
peut-être poussé à chanter pour les
enfants aussi non parce que du coup
c'était un peu dans l'idée ça c'est des
chansons qu'on faisait que pour la télé
c'était pas pour un disque
tu devrais faire cette chanson la
refaire et mon papa est parti à ce
moment-là
de télévision
et puis du coup j'ai refait la chanson
et puis j'ai chanté et personne n'en
voulait si ça commence bien bah dis donc
je voyais le public le public comme
d'habitude qui était comme des fous qui
voulaient la chanson qui voulait que je
vienne et le métier comprenait rien mais
nous on a Claude François on s'en fiche
dit bon ben alors dans ce cas là c'est
ça dans la voiture et un jour on l'a
rencontré quelqu'un de merveilleux qui
s'appelait François da clap PDG RCA qui
m'a dit qu'est-ce qu'on fait de cette
chanson j'ai Laborde dans la voiture je
viens 7h du matin j'ai devant son bureau
avec la banque en plastique il a sorti
et Bing 1 million dix et alors le déclic
pour chanter les chansons pour enfants
c'est venu comment il y a pas de chanson
pour enfants elle ressemble pas fan
chanson pour les adultes j'avais une
voix d'enfants c'est pas pour les
enfants Bécassine mais c'est pas fini
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
génial ça c'était parti à l'île de la
Réunion j'avais amené tous les
personnages allez hop sur la plage
quel titre vous voulez écouter encore
parce que là le petit
ourson qui roulait qui goût sur la boxe
[Musique]
attendez attendez attendez attendez tous
ces titres je voudrais que les girls
viennent danser parce que vous étiez
comme des fois tout à l'heure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bon c'est bon
absolument et alors il y a le spectacle
de Marie-Rose aussi il y a la poupée de
sucre qui sort
tellement on a mis je crois 30 ans ou 40
ans pour que ça sorte c'était sur la
chaîne TF1 et finalement on est arrivé
grâce à vos producteurs et ça sort le 5
juillet 5 juillet
c'était très joli pour Noël à l'époque
alors je sais aussi tu sais que des
copains et tes copains avec Johnny tu as
reçu Johnny chez toi aussi à une époque
il a même vécu chez toi parce que Sylvie
et moi on attendait nos enfants ensemble
et que David est né au mois d'août et
mon fils au mois de juin
il était dans sa chambre et puis après
il me dit je peux amener des copains je
veux oui je n'étais chez toi peu là sans
bike s'appelle
petite rue dans Paris il y avait Sylvie
Vartan aussi ou pas là parce qu'elle
faisait beaucoup de chorégraphies aux
États-Unis
oui j'aime beaucoup
sa belle histoire parce que c'est quand
même une petite fille qui a rencontré un
jour Jean-Jacques Debout elle arrivait
de Bulgarie lui écrit sa première
chanson qui était tous mes copains
et c'était si joli cette chanson et pour
Johnny pour moi la vie va commencer dans
les années 60 il a connu Jean-Jacques et
Johnny Sylvie et Johnny très très jeune
ils les a présentés et puis comme il a
compris qu'il s'aimait tous les deux il
a quitté la tournée Jean-Jacques qui les
aime cette idée
tu vois tu l'as tu as traversé toutes
les générations ou te connaît depuis
déjà très longtemps tu sais
qu'actuellement le grand mot à la mode
si j'ose dire c'est la retraite est-ce
que tu penses à ça est-ce que c'est un
mot que tu connais ça
et puis la semaine et puis là demain je
m'en vais à Mâcon puis je reviens
dimanche et puis je repartirai après
dans l'Est bah la retraite je comprends
qu'on a besoin d'avoir une retraite
parce que quand les gens sont très
fatigués ont travaillé toute leur vie et
ont été très très dur quand on travaille
dur le matin moi c'est pas du travail ce
que je fais si donner du rêve et
j'espère tout le monde qui pouvait le
faire un jour soit comme moi parce que
c'est pas c'est pas ça le travail pour
moi pour moi c'est de donner du rêve
donner du bonheur mais au travail jour
et nuit et qu'on est fatigué et ben il
faut se reposer c'est important c'est le
contraire je suis trop active mais
Jean-Jacques il se repose à la maison
on habite à la campagne maintenant alors
il est très très important pour lui de
se reposer parce que il a vécu à Paris
jour et nuit et là maintenant c'est
important à son âge donc je suis
toujours là pour lui préparer des bonnes
choses
que ça sorte parce que vraiment toute ma
famille m'a emmené à tous vos concerts
donc quand un pouvait pas où vous voulez
plus c'était un autre donc il se
relayait pour que je n'en rate aucun
donc bravo pour tous les moments que
vous nous avez fait passer à moi et à
tous les petits français et moi ce que
je voudrais savoir c'est vous avez deux
enfants vous en avez parlé est-ce qu'ils
ont pas été un moment donné un petit peu
jaloux justement de de tout l'amour que
les autres petits Français pouvaient
vous porter certainement avoir leur
maman que pour certainement j'ai
toujours été moi je suis une Gémeaux je
suis double donc je suis celle qui est
sur la scène et celle qui est à la
maison et je me souviens que quand
j'étais au palais des corrects ils
étaient petits là ils sont à la maison
dans ma chambre et dans la chambre je me
débrouiller pour qu'ils aient toujours
quelqu'un qu'ils aimaient près d'eux
alors un membre de la famille une
cousine une nièce et puis même des fois
on l'avait un bar en bas de chez nous un
café bon pour plus faire ça aujourd'hui
que ça fait le truc et l'âme qui était
la langue de la rue de Grenelle alors
qui venait là HB HL Bernard Henri Lévy
Mitterrand il met deux enfants habillés
en pyjama qui allaient manger leurs
secrets puis remontait à la maison mais
tout était préparé pour qu'il soit
heureux bon c'est vrai que c'est des
moments où j'ai pas été là souvent le
week-end j'étais pas là mais comme ils
m'ont dit on était content parce qu'on
avait nos copains tu avais bien préparé
les choses et on pouvait faire ce qu'on
voulait quoi mais ils ont toujours été
très rigolo parce que je leur avais bien
expliqué à l'âge de 14-15 ans que enfin
même avant qu'il y a des moments
difficiles dans la vie et qu'il faut pas
se laisser avoir Déborah j'ai remarqué
en regardant les photos vous avez la
même coupe de cheveux depuis la première
fois que vous vend photos
ma coiffure un jour ma grand-mère m'a
dit qu'il faut mettre une barrette là
alors j'ai mis pour lui faire plaisir
puis je l'ai enlevé puis voilà
mais c'est vrai que vous pouvez faire
travailler tous ces gens ils sont
magnifiques tu as raison d'aller à Paris
toujours à Paris alors moi je vais à la
campagne la scène ça donne une longévité
à la vie mais qu'est-ce que tu fais pour
avoir autant de patates j'en ai
naturellement je fais rien je fais aucun
sport je fais pas de régime je passe ma
vie le matin je me lève à 9h j'emmène
les chiens dans le parc là-bas pour
qu'il court je leur fais balle machin
tout ce que c'est parti
passe mon temps à courir partout après
je me dis non ça y est le volet de
Jean-Jacques vient de s'ouvrir j'ai vite
lui préparer son petit déj je prépare
tout alors là la chance
tu sais je suis comme une cheftaine moi
c'est j'étais j'étais le médecin enfant
donc à la maison c'était moi qui
préparais tout donc j'ai gardé cette
habitude même en tournée pour les filles
pour tout le monde je suis en train
d'organiser tout il y a rien à faire
vous avez pas eu de dessert mais c'est
pas normal hop je vais chercher des
desserts non mais c'est mon c'est mon
instinct d'être une fille de la famille
l'aîné l'aîné de la famille et puis il
fallait bouger à la maison restez pas à
rien faire bravo
et ici ici là dans cette lieux magique
je suis venu faire la figuration dans
les animaux dans le centre avec Audrey
burn et là j'avais un petit escalier il
y avait une nana qui avait un tablier je
dis qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la
vie il me dit bah je monte le thé à
Audrey bird tu crois monter le thé
attendez passez-moi le tablier le
plateau je veux monter elle me l'a passé
j'ai monté j'ai voilà quand je parlais
bien anglais oh je suis son sweet il m'a
demandé si vous voulez tourner dans le
film yes yes alors ils m'ont mis en
train de danser avec un marin j'étais
content mais qu'est-ce que je me suis
engueuler mon par mon père parce qu'il
me cherchait partout il m'a vu il m'a vu
il m'a vu au cinéma avec le marin on
dansait on rigole
merveilleuses
on a envie de te dire bah cherche
Chantal c'est que tu sois avec nous très
longtemps encore parce qu'on t'adore on
te veut encore 20 30 40 ans avec nous
Chantal Goya
tu démarre donc je le dis sa nouvelle
tournée sur la route enchantée jusqu'au
25 novembre 2020 le 14 octobre au Palais
des Congrès
apparaît une trentaine de gâtes dans
toute la France je rappelle le DVD la
poupée de ceux qui sort le 5 juillet
prochain effectivement et vous retrouvez
pour la première fois en DVD l'intégrale
des 9 épisodes de la série culte de
mariti et Gilbert Carpentier aussi en
1983 sur TF1 voilà et précommande
dédicacée sur la boutique de
marie-rose.com tu vois je dis tout
magenta merci beaucoup ma Chantal
[Musique]